Next question. My right light bulb has malfunction. The cord leading to the bulb has a cut in it,
so it sparks and causes the bulb to make sizzling noises. Well, that's not good because we're
trying to create frequencies to help heal your cancer and we're not cooking bacon. So sizzling
noises are not a good thing to be hearing from your bulb or from the cords. Question is can this
be fixed or can I purchase a new one? How would I purchase that? What should I do? So that's another
issue. It doesn't repair those things. They would just say you just need to buy a new one.
I can't repair those things. So you know, I just don't have the skills to take your bulb apart without
losing the gas because your bulb is a gas-filled tube and you have to have the machinery to be able to
resolder that on correctly and for it to work correctly to put a new wire on there. So really,
you just need to get a new one. You can order it directly from TrueRife or you can order from
our website. If you order directly from TrueRife, you're going to get their little new model. It is
a little more expensive. I still have some of the older model bulbs on our website. I just had
a collection of them. So you know, you could get it from there. Usually, so how does this happen?
How do you get a cut in the in the cord? In 99% of the time, it's because you got caught underneath
a rocking chair or something like that or that's your, just like you could get a cut in any extension
cord, it got snagged on something. So the worst, the biggest thing for the bulbs is a rocking chair.
So I damaged my cord the same way and had to get a new bulb of a while ago. So you could just go
on our store in order from our store. It's less expensive because it's the older model, but it's
still a new bulb.